do it in public well maybe don't do it
in public that kind of came out wrong
but do your thing in public whatever
you're good at whatever mission you're
on whatever you're trying to change in
the world whatever your businesses you
should be trying to have an impact right
you can have a message that is worth
spreading you should be leading a
movement and for that to happen you got
to be comfortable doing it in public
this this came out of a tweet that my
agent Hank posted on Twitter and he said
stand for something and do it in public
then don't be afraid and when I first
started making these videos I did it in
my basement in a small room and I had to
have somebody help me set up the focus
and press record and then they left
because I had to be on myself and it
took me all day to make one video and I
thought it sucked and it took me forever
and I slowly got better I slowly made
things better and then I got less
nervous doing it by myself and then I
did it with people in the room and I
film that I was at my office or was at
my house and somebody walked in and I
got nervous all of a sudden I'm worried
that they might judge me I think that I
wasn't doing a good job and so I stopped
how you doing there goes the postman and
you see him there he was so I stopped
they made me nervous they made me doubt
myself I wondered you know what if they
didn't didn't like it you know I thought
they would judge me and so I didn't do
as well and then it took me a long time
to get used to that now I'm fine if I'm
in the office it's my my family's there
my coworkers are there I'm okay with it
I don't get nervous I don't worry about
their judgment if I'm gonna on TV I
don't worry about it but doing it in
public is a whole other thing you know
yeah I'm just walking on the street and
here goes the postman right people are
walking by and I'm worried about the
judgment
and so this going to be my my next thing
to to grow you know you want to do
something that challenges yourself that
pushes yourself and I encourage you to
get out there and do something in public
whatever message you have the spread in
the world whatever you're trying to do
hopefully is powerful right hopefully
something that will inspire people you
want to create that movement and you
should be unafraid eventually to get out
there I'm people to do it and say it in
public with random people walking by
it's your next test so get out there
pick up your phone get outside record
something something powerful something
that will hopefully help change people's
lives and it's going to be scary at the
start but it's just going to come with
practice I've done like 700 plus videos
now and everyone gets better and better
and better and you over to yourself your
friends your community the people around
you to get out there and do it in public
believe you want to see more of these
leave a comment below give it a thumbs
up I love doing it just for you thank
you guys I'll see you soon